Speaker 1: Let's keep talking a little bit
about foreign policy.
One other Joe Biden foreign policy note.
Joe Biden did have a call, phone call with
Russian President Vladimir Putin.
And I'm going to say this in a particular
way, but I'm not necessarily attaching value
judgment to it.
Joe Biden stood up to Vladimir Putin during
this phone call in a way that Donald Trump
never did.
Now, that doesn't mean we're cheering for
Joe Biden to go to war with Russia.
We're not this doesn't mean we are cheering
for Joe Biden to be unnecessarily hostile
or adversarial with Vladimir Putin.
This is it almost shouldn't even be a big
deal that this is how Joe Biden managed the
phone call with Vladimir Putin.
It's just not the way Donald Trump operated.
Donald Trump was enamored by and deferred
to various authoritarian leaders around the
world.
We now have a readout from the White House
and we will look at it together.
This was released yesterday.
It reads, President Joseph R. Biden Jr. spoke
today with President Vladimir Putin of Russia.
They discussed a number of regional and global
issues, including the intent of the United
States and Russia to pursue a strategic stability
dialog on a range of armed arms control and
emerging security issues, building on the
extension of the new START treaty.
President Biden also made clear that the United
States will act firmly in defense of its natural
natural national interests in response to
Russia's actions, such as cyber intrusions
and election interference, specifically referring
to the cyber intrusions that we know Russia
was involved in recently and the election
interference that we know Russia attempted
recently.
The readout goes on to say President Biden
emphasized the United States unwavering commitment
to Ukraine's sovereignty and territorial integrity.
The president voiced our concerns over the
sudden Russian military buildup in occupied
Crimea on Ukraine's borders and called on
Russia to deescalate tensions.
President Biden reaffirmed his goal of building
a stable and predictable relationship with
Russia consistent with U.S. interests, and
proposed a summit meeting in a third country
in the coming months.
This is you know, it's not a big deal in that
this is how most presidents deal with other
adversaries who we know have geopolitical
ambitions that may be out of conflict with
those of the United States.
It's not about picking a side.
It's we have countries, nation states exist.
We have multinational collaboration.
We have treaties, we have agreements.
And we expect our leaders to look out for
the best interests of our country.
That's it.
And that's already more than Donald Trump
ever did.
Biden released the content of the call.
Nobody ate the notes.
I mean, remember what I'm talking about, that
there was the story of Omarosa, who said that
she walked in on Donald Trump eating paper
after a meeting with Michael Cohen in what
she believed was an effort to destroy sensitive
information.
OK, that's the reference with eating paper.
Unlike the previous administration, the fact
that we have this readout also means that
the entire transcript of this call is available
to intelligence members that have the appropriate
clearance and access as opposed to never being
created, as was the case with some of Donald
Trump's conversations with Vladimir Putin.
So everything is being managed in a completely
different way.
It's not about we want war with Russia.
It's not about militarism.
We just want a president that's firm and isn't
obviously railroaded by every authoritarian
autocrat that he talks to and seems taken
with.
Remember Trump displeased with Angela Merkel,
displeased with for a period of time.
Theresa May displeased with Justin.
Doe and Emmanuel Macron are traditional allies,
but taken by Putin's shows of strength, impressed
by Kim Jong un.
It was very, very backwards.
And so this is without war.
Nobody's rallying for war.
You know, there's going to be some on the
revolutionary left who will say that a commentary
like mine is beating drums of war against
Russia or arguing for a hostility.
We're not doing any of those things.
It's simply a president who is able to be
cordial but firm in a phone call with another
world leader.
It's a president who's not so impressed with
himself that he's even having the conversation
and is just able to be railroaded and bamboozled
by anyone.
It's just a president who understands geopolitics
and understands how you deal with these situations.
So I think there's a lot of good signs here
of Joe Biden in the last 24 hours, firm with
Putin in a phone call saying, we are getting
out of Afghanistan.
There is a date certain we're getting out
on September 11th, 20 21.
These are good signs geopolitically in terms
of foreign policy from Joe Biden.
Doesn't mean he's going to do everything right,
doesn't mean we'll agree with everything he
does.
But certainly much of the fear mongering from
from the right and some on the left as well
about Joe Biden's going to invade everybody
and expand our presence.
And it does not seem to be what he's doing
for the time being.
And that's a good thing.
I'm glad to see that.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman